im zweiten teil der eigenen prüfung wird
deine aussage des add und das passiert
mit einem 2400 meter lauf ich gebe jetzt
wie du deine austausch steigern kann und
sich gut auf den 2400 meter lauf
vorbereitet startete mit einem testlauf
die 2400 meter auf der bahn und stoppt
einer zeit und einer leistung zu
steigern
reicht es schon regelmäßige einheiten
über 30 bis 45 minuten zu laufen
zusätzlich kann auch ein
intervalltraining machen weg eine neue
ziel fest und 17 prozent ab radu die
einzelnen intervalle schneller laufen
soll falls die gesamtstrecke ein
beispiel die 2400 meter läuft derzeit in
zwölf minuten
du willst dich auf 11 minuten verbessern
beim intervalltraining teil für die 2400
meter und gleiche abschnitte zum
beispiel sechs intervalle zu je 400
meter jetzt willst du die zeit um 400
meter intervall wissen 14 prozent von
den elf minuten ab das ergibt neun
minuten und 54 sekunden
diese zeit erst dann durch sechs dh für
jede 400 meter intervall hast du eine
minute und 39 sekunden macht zwischen
den intervallen kurze pausen bei diesem
beispiel wären circa eine minute die
grundlagenausdauer kannst du auch mit
sportarten wie mountainbiken und
inlineskaten verbessern
natürlich sollte das laufen nicht zu
kurz kommen mit drei lauftrainings pro
woche ist das sicher fit ist